in 3 2 1
light we've basically been starting
fires
[Music]
[Applause]
here Fred will be here Adam will be here
Linda will be over here but she'll be
out
God we challenging part was any of like
the big stunts that we've had to do in
studio because while Studio work is
really nice because it's always in like
one location everything that you know
making sure that we get all the stunts
done in a safe and timely manner uh and
making sure that everyone's comfortable
with what we're
doing the scene where uh David jumps
like kind of Falls onto Adam um that was
a really cool scene to shoot especially
since we had to do that a number of
times for the retakes re-shoot and stuff
I think the second time around we shot
that is going to look
[Music]
amazing probably most excited for the
void this is the void set welcome to the
[Music]
void
action or the stunt cuz those are both
really intense scenes that you're going
to have to watch to find out why ready
we're going back to
on
I'm excited for all the fire we have
some incredible fire from our special
effects fire safety teams where we
actually burnt our set
[Music]
down today we uh the big gag was the
kitchen
fire 3 2 1
light o and as he starts bringing it
down I'm going to go
Vim okay and then you start as fast as
you can bring it back and then and then
and then I'm just going to go 3 2 1 pop
we all clear y 3 2 one
[Music]
light and it was all a very complicated
Domino of bottle
explodes stove ignite
and then the whole wall catches fire and
the entire
kitchen the door's there I was sitting
there and I felt the heat we had bodies
Lighting on fire
there
[Music]
the fire was really really cool and the
shots turned out great for
[Music]
that we had to paint all of the
cupboards down with a a gasoline paste
that we use spray everything and we had
pyot Technics we had electric
[Music]
matches I would say the most challenging
thing uh for us has been the
cats I'm really excited for you to see
the cats they performed incredibly well
so the actors in in this film that are
the most like their true selves I would
say are the cats definitely the
cats penguin and Puffin the cats they
play cats perfectly you would never
[Music]
believe